But I feel like
the common thread
with maybe marriage
and sketch comedy is commitment.
Like, you got to have
commitment for both, right?
You do.
You really do. Yeah.
I mean, isn't that the key?
I mean, I've never been
a sketch player.
You are the genius--
to my view, genius
sketch player of all time.
I mean, you've-- Seriously.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDS)
-I'm not just saying that
'cause you're here.
I've always believed that.
Even when you insulted me,
I believed that.
You're a genius at what you do.
But it is about commitment,
right?
You always commit one billion
percent to the character.
There's never any doubt
you're in it all the way.
Yeah. Yeah, I--
To me, it's always--
To me, sketch performing
is just acting.
I try to act as seriously
within the sketch
as Meryl Streep would
-in any drama.
-BILL MAHER: Right.
You know, because the thing
is that what--
you want to be a mile deep
in the commitment.
Not only-- Not only
of you to the character,
but the character
to the situation
-they find themselves in.
-MAHER: Right.
And that's always been
important to me is that
I wanted to make sure
that I'm playing it
as deep as possible,
so that--
'Cause it's not about me
winking or laughing,
it's about you guys laughing.
And it's about giving
as much commitment to the--
to the project as possible.
And this, I feel like
Key & Peele...
(APPLAUSE)
I mean, I'm watching
Key & Peele now again,
-because it's--
they just put it on Netflix.
-KEEGAN-MICHAEL KEY: Right.
I mean, I always watched them
when they've come
the first time.
Probably watched it twice.
So probably, I'm watching it
the third time now.
Stands the test of time,
which is not something you can
say about a lot of comedy.
I mean, I--
going through your book,
I mean, you give, you know,
a lot of props to people.
But I must say, like when
you watch old shows, they--
Humor is not like music.
People want to hear the music
from 50 years ago.
You watch a sketch
from 50 years ago...
KEY: Doesn't stand up.
-It really-- It rarely does.
-KEY: Rarely stands up.
-Your shit does.
-KEY: Yeah.
It's still exactly--
It really does.
-(APPLAUSE)
-It's amazing.
But like, things change.
Like, I feel like you guys,
you know,
you give great props
to Carol Burnett.
-KEY: Mm-hmm.
-Which, right in this building.
-KEY: Yeah.
-Where that show was done.
-Yeah.
-Okay.
Saturday Night Live
and Carol Burnett
kind of overlapped
as sketch shows, right?
But very different.
Carol Burnett, they were like
always cracking each other up.
Right? Harvey Korman
and Tim Conway-- (LAUGHS)
They couldn't get through
the sketch without laughing
-at what they were doing.
-KEY: Yeah.
Saturday Night Live was like,
"That's fucking corny."
-(CHUCKLING)
-KEY: That's right.
"We don't do that anymore."
And they never did.
And that just shows
things change.
So, when you watch
a Carol Burnett sketch,
it does look a little museum-y.
KEY: Hm. Interesting.
-Interesting. (LAUGHS)
-I think--
(LAUGHTER)
KEY: I can feel--
I can feel Harvey Korman's ghost
over my shoulder.